this week senators from both parties
head back to the negotiating table over
new gun legislation not far from capitol
hill a shooting last night killed a
15-year-old and injured three adults
including a police officer it happened
after a fight broke out at an
unpermitted music event that drew
hundreds of people meanwhile we found
search for solutions is hitting other
roadblocks a cbs news investigation
shows credit card industry they're
blocking an effort to track certain
firearm and ammunition purchases that
deprives law enforcement of potentially
identifying and stopping illegal gun
crimes chief investigative correspondent
jim axelrod has a story jim good morning
well good morning frustrated by
legislative failures gun reform
advocates in 2018 look to the financial
system to stop guns from falling into
the hands of dangerous individuals
what they found weren't politicians
standing in the way but a little-known
technical committee whose members
include employees of some of the biggest
names in business visa mastercard and
american express
so much illegal gun activity
depends on your ability to use the
financial system to buy the guns
priscilla sims brown is the ceo of
amalgamated bank founded by union
workers nearly a hundred years ago the
bank bills itself as the nation's oldest
socially responsible bank we believe you
can do well and do good that urge to do
good struck after the bank noticed some
of the deadliest mass shootings were
being financed with credit cards
the shooter who terrorized a colorado
movie theater in 2012 charged more than
nine thousand dollars worth of guns ammo
and tactical gear in two months
the man who shot up the pulse nightclub
in orlando put more than 26 thousand
dollars on credit cards
and the shooter who killed 59 at a las
vegas music festival charged almost 95
000. people aren't bringing sacks of
cash exactly they use credit cards they
use credit cards amalgamator believed it
could run software to detect suspect
purchases in the same way it detected
evidence of other suspicious activity
like fraud and human trafficking where
there may be gun sales that are intended
for
black markets where we see patterns of
gun purchases being made and multiple
gun shops so there are algorithms that
could be written exactly and we could
provide that information
to the authorities to investigate
they're called suspicious activity
reports and banks and credit unions made
more than 1.4 million of them in 2021
flagging transactions that might suggest
everything from identity theft to
terrorist financing
but when it came to guns
amalgamated discovered it was missing
what it says was a key piece of
information to report suspicious
purchases an individual merchant code
unique to firearm sellers you might be
a nail salon you might be a sporting
goods store there's a merchant category
code assigned to you so that we can see
that purchase has been made and while
even shoe shine parlors have their own
merchant code the nearly 9 000
stand-alone u.s gun sellers do not we
actually submitted an application
to try and get that changed that
application went here last year to a
geneva switzerland-based organization
which sets standards across the
financial services industry
you apply to a panel a committee of
sorts
it includes uh credit card companies
mastercard visa american express they
all have representatives on this correct
this committee that's right documents
obtained by cbs news show the credit
card industry pushed back the swiss
agency said card company representatives
only acted as advisors and were there in
a personal capacity but amalgamated's
application was rejected
twice the bank was told a code for gun
and ammo sellers wouldn't identify the
sales at sporting goods stores and the
burden primarily would fall on small
retailers wait a minute there's a code
literally for a shoe shine stall yes and
there's not a code for a gun an
ammunition store yes it's just so
obvious it's hard to deny the logic
financial institutions provide
information to law enforcement on a
regular basis former senior special
agent jim urgolitis spent more than two
decades investigating gun crime for the
atf would law enforcement benefit from a
stand-alone merchant category code for
firearms i believe so especially if
you're talking about large purchase
amounts visa mastercard and american
express all didn't say if they supported
creating a merchant code for firearm
sellers when asked by cbs news in a
statement mastercard said it was up to
elected officials to address the issue
of gun violence what do you think of
credit card companies that say it's not
our responsibility
well this is our responsibility we
have an obligation
to address crime
that is being facilitated through our
system and if somebody says but it's
just gonna
at best
make a small difference
what price do you put on a life
if it stops two people from dying isn't
that worth it
in statements to cbs news american
express and mastercard said they are
working to ensure only lawful purchases
are permitted on their networks the
swiss standards organization said the
card industry reps who pushed back on
amalgamated's application acted based on
their expertise and do not represent the
views of their employer
after we began reaching out amalgamated
also heard from the standards
organization telling the bank
how it could now reapply for the code
which amalgamated said it plans to do
this week i like that priscilla since
brown number one she did not stutter
when she said it is our responsibility
yeah i've never heard of that merchant
code category
shoes shoe places have it that's right
it's not and to her point she said look
whether you're a gun owner or not if
you're a law abiding citizen why
wouldn't you support something right
that could keep the guns out of the
hands of people who shouldn't have
buying them in a suspicious fashion and
as it currently stands you can't tell if
the person's buying footballs and hockey
equipment or firearms and if it's used
for human trafficking if it's used to
root out mortgage fraud
why can't we and like you said if the
saves won life
it's worth it people need to call
priscilla sims brown he's got some good
ideas thank you jim good to have you at
the table too